avec nous maintenant jean yves duclos le
ministre fédérale de la santé bonsoir
monsieur duclos
écoute alors messieurs duclos vous fait
cette annonce pour le 1er avril de la
fin des tests là pour les gens qui
arrivent au canada ça fait quand même
quand on regarde ailleurs dans le monde
un mois un mois et demi je pense au
royaume uni par exemple la france qui
ont laissé tomber les tests à l'arrivée
depuis déjà un certain temps pourquoi
vous avez au gouvernement du canada
attendu autant
bien effectivement on peut toujours
trouver des pays qui vont parfois plus
parfois plus lentement moi je vous
rappelle par exemple que les états unis
ont encore peut-être pour un certain
temps le déteste pour pouvoir arriver
chez eux par voie aérienne alors au
canada on fait les choses sur la base
des données que l'on a à la base la
situation épidémiologique et qu'on
observe et ce qu'on a observé au cours
des dernières semaines c'est que comme
on l'espérait il ya eu des croissance
rapide du taux de productivité parmi les
voyageurs qui rentrait au canada
aujourd'hui on est capable de monter
cette bonne nouvelle à partir du 1er mai
ce que ça vient pas un peu tard quand
même aujourd'hui on parlait au
regroupement de l'industrie des
événements d'affaires qui nous disait la
réputation du canada souffre beaucoup de
la tante de l'hésitation il ya beaucoup
d'évènements qui vont à lille là où ils
sont bienvenus est ce que ça ne nuit pas
l'économie d'avoir autant attendu
mais ce qu'on entend bon effectivement
c'est qu'on aimerait tous que la coved
19e
n'existe pas 1,2 au micro ondes et pas
glisser puisqu'on attend aussi de la
part des acteurs de l'industrie c'est
que le canada est réputée comme étant
une destination sûre et solide au cours
des prochaines semaines et des prochains
mois avec ce que j'entends et avec ce
que mes collègues ministres entendent
hausser on a très confiance dans le
rebond de l'industrie touristique tpt
l'industrie du transport les gens vont
vouloir venir au canada parce qu'on est
le pays qui a bien géré la corvée 19
soit où les gens peuvent se sentir en
sécurité lorsqu'ils vont voyager pour
rentrer au pays mais lorsqu'ils seront
aussi au pays dont pour se promener et
visiter les attractions à travers le
pays est-ce que la saison estivale
puisque on a attendu jusqu'au bout
jusqu'à la et mars dans le fond ou à la
mi mars pour le 1er avril
d'autres pays ont envoyé des messages
d'accueil aux touristes beaucoup plus
tôt cette année est-ce que vous pèse et
skull l'industrie touristique va
connaître une autre année un autre été
mi figue mi raisin
à bien deux jours de prenait assez
connaître des gens comme vous savez
relâché changer les règles d'entrée à la
frontière il ya déjà quelques semaines
de ça ce qui facilite et les tests le
pastis et des tests antigènes des temps
qui était possible moins coûteux plus
facilement accéder par définition plus
rapide la deuxième chose que j'entends
est ce que l'on entend aussi dans ma
propre circonscription dans la propre
région de québec c'est qu'on peut
s'attendre certainement souhaité que la
saison sauvée c'est que 2022 à partir du
printemps donc très bientôt durant tout
l'été y compris à l'automne fait une
très bonne saison ok votre gouvernement
a investi je vous emmène dans le dossier
medicago la 130 millions de dollars dans
medicago le ms dit on pourrait rejeter
le vaccin de medicago en raison de
l'actionnariat du producteur de tabac
philip morris d'abord est-ce que ça
cette information là vous surprend
oui ça me surprend un peu en fait de
deux choses qui qui que je pense qu'ils
sont de très bonnes nouvelles avant
parler de la surprise vient de bonne
nouvelle c'est que cette technologie est
une technologie végétale la seule au
monde que quiconque a permis de faire
homologuer un vaccin et la grande
nouvelle c'est au québec à québec et au
canada qu'on a trouvé ça la deuxième
chose c'est ce vaccin est très bon aussi
bon d'ailleurs que les autres vaccins
d'autres technologies qu'on a pu
approuver au cours des derniers mois
mais en plus il est refusé par l' oms
finie la bonne nouvelle
on a espoir que l' oms va prendre la
bonne décision quand vous l'avez plus
que vous l'avez noté il ya apparemment
un enjeu sur la nature corporatives
medicago on est en contact évidemment
avec m medicago mon collègue françois
fédé de champagne est aussi responsable
du développement économique et la
science est en contact avec hulu oms ou
six pour s'assurer que ces informations
que j'ai résumé qui sont de très bonnes
informations soient bien entendu par
l'homme et l'eau et baisse on parle
d'une technologie qui peut être très
bonne pour les canadiens pour les
protéger mais aussi très bonne pour nous
autres gens qui habitent en dehors du
pays qu'est ce qui doit arriver monsieur
le ministre est-ce que philip morris
doit sortir de l'actionnariat pour que
l'om ait ça prouve le vaccin de medicago
elle a coûté alors l'on est à l'étape il
faut clarifier les choses entre medicago
est louée baisse à nouveau certainement
moi comme ministre de la santé et
ministre et les rangs du québec je suis
très policé c'est très enthousiaste par
rapport à la valeur de ce vaccin
solitaire maintenant s'il ya des choses
à clarifier le web et sur ce que doit
être le président est-ce qu'on peut
utiliser nous medicago canada parce que
vous avez quand même une heure une
entente jusqu'à 76 millions de doses du
vaccin de medicago n'est ce pas si les
oms dit non vaccin
will agences réglementaires l'agencé
réglementaire de santé canada qui est
une des mieux reconnues au monde déjà
établi que ce lac sainte et la fois
sécuritaire et efficace et très bon et 2
go par rapport à d'autres technologies
donc c'est une très bonne nouvelle pour
les canadiens et on veut ce soin de soi
une très bonne nouvelle pour tout être
humain le kabyle en dehors du pays et
qui peut se faire actionner par cette
taxe un qui fonctionne bien sur une
technologie innovatrice qui serait
banale raffour d'autres sites de
maladies à l'avenir merci monsieur
culture d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
merci bonsoir à tout le monde pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne i r d